(UUUM社員の方が会話中)
UUUM社員)あ、どうぞ
は)あ、すみません、すぐ終わりますすぐ終わります...
みなさんこんにちは はじめしゃちょーの畑総支配人　はじめしゃちょーです
失礼致しまし た
決して毎年やるわけではありませんが今年もやってまいりました
はじめしゃちょーの畑 新メンバー オーディションを開催いたします
はじめしゃちょーの畑　今ではチャンネル 登録者数が 140万 人を超え
約 1 年 で ここまで やってまいりました
この オーディションでは
普段
はじめしゃちょーの
畑 に は
沢山 の
小汚い 出演 者 が い ます が
オーディション に 受かっ た 方 に は
はじめしゃちょーの畑 の 出演 のみ で は なく
動画 の ネタ の 考案
動画 編集 など を 含む
常習的なはじめしゃちょーの畑 の 運営 に 携わっ て 頂き たい と 考え て おり ます
現 時点 で の 常駐メンバー
該当 する常駐メンバー と いたし まし て は
だいちぃ
やふへい先生
トマトクン
そして 私 はじめしゃちょー
棚澤龍が 該当 し て おり ます
この オーディション に 受かっ た 方 に は
私 はじめしゃちょー
そして はじめしゃちょーの 畑 と とも に
動画 制作
ポケカ
遊戯王
パズドラ
モンストなどの様々な分野でともに活動しtっ…
とも に 活動 し て いけれ ば いい な と 思っ て おり ます オーディション の 募集期間ですが
2019 年 3 月 16 日 の 土曜日 から
2019 年 3 月 の ２２ 日 の 金曜日
23:59 まで と さ せ て いただき ます
LINE来 まし た その 他 の 詳しい オーディション の 内容 に つき まし て は
動画 の 概要 欄 の url に ござい ます の で ぜひ そちら の ご 確認 を よろしく お 願い 致し ます
それ で は はじめしゃちょーの 畑 新 メンバー オーディション
たくさん の ご 応募 を お 待ち し て おり ます